[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rose I'm the
executive director here at long now and
over the last 10 years of this series
we've been lucky enough to have the
Margaret and will Hearst foundation
funding the media that goes out the
podcast and the video comes out about
1.2 million people a year are viewing
that so it's one of our largest outputs
of kind of long now content the as many
of you may know we have a new venue not
too new anymore
how many of you have been to the
interval nice awesome
so we've been filming talks there now
for actually three years I think this
month because we started doing some of
the talks before we even before we even
open to the to the public starting with
I think Adam Rogers but we've had talks
like Neil Stevenson Rachel Sussman and
Adam Rogers amazing speakers Kim Stanley
Robinson we filmed all of them but we
haven't had funding to to do the editing
until recently when the Elks Family
Foundation was able to to put forth some
money so that we can start editing we've
got I think we'll be putting up about 14
to 16 of those with the new interval
website very shortly and the clips from
some of those some of the highlights of
those have been going up starting over
the weekend actually and we'll be going
up over the the next few weeks so look
out for those and also look out for the
new website and then hopefully over time
we'll be actually editing and putting up
all of the interval content as well so
hopefully you can enjoy that with that
I'll give you Stuart
all right long now foundation is all
about scale thinking long and thinking
big and when it comes to doing good
these days it's also I think useful to
think big think scale think global long
now is also kind of engineering based
and we're into geekery and I'd say the
world's leading do-good geek is here to
speak yarn lombard thank you very much
it's a great pleasure to be here and
thanks a lot for the invite what I'd
like to talk to you about for the next
50 minutes is really how we can think
about a better way to do as much good as
we possibly can and what I'd also like
to convince you about is really that
there's a way that each one of us if we
try to push our governments and if we
try to push our philanthropists to spend
money in the best possible way we can do
amazing good we can actually and I'll
try and show you that but we can
actually do more good than Bill Gates
and this is you know obviously not
because you suddenly have you know 60
billion dollars in your bank account but
it's because we can actually make sure
that we can leverage that much money
that's being spent out there and do so
much more good so that's really what I
want to talk about here today so let's
just get started
I'm gonna tell you about everything we
can do in the world and so just in 50
minutes I I hope you're appreciate I'm
gonna go a little fast and a lot of
these different things but you can
definitely go on our website and see all
the intricacies and I'm gonna try and
give you sort of the gist of why this is
as it is and then hopefully we'll also
have some good conversation afterwards
when we talk about the the question so
look there are lots of challenges in the
world but the amazing thing is there's
also lots of good solutions but the real
question is how do we pick
unfortunately very often how do we get
intention to a problem well typically we
get attention if they're cute animals
all right there lots of crying babies or
if they're groups with great PR and
surely that's sometimes the right way to
prioritize but it's not the right way in
general we shouldn't just do something
because it has cute animals or crying
babies or great PR some of the most
important things are the boring problem
so this is where the key comes in so
really how should you prioritize well
you should certainly scrutinize the
options carefully right you have to
remember to read the fine print I gave
this talk another place admittedly they
were a little drunk and he was like yay
I know the first written first reaction
but the reality is you need in order to
prioritize you need a menu with prices
and sizes and that's what we try to
provide imagine if you see this cool you
can create your own pizza for $19.99
that sounds like a nice deal but imagine
if you had this sort of menu but you had
no prices unless you're in a good
expense account that would make you a
little uncomfortable to order that
create your own pizza right your no idea
whether it's gonna cost $0.99 or whether
it's gonna cost a thousand dollars all
right and you have no idea of size
either you've no idea whether you're
gonna get a very very tiny pizza
or that Pizza is gonna serve your entire
party and then some and so that's why I
think we need to start talking about
when we discuss what are we gonna do we
need to know what are we going to get
for our money and that's really the menu
that we're trying to do Mike my my
think-tank the Copenhagen consensus so
we try to estimate all the cost in
dollars there's there's typically just
economic but every once in a while
they'll also be social and environmental
cost and we try to accumulate all of
them and express them in dollars
likewise then we try to estimate all the
benefits in dollars that's a little more
controversial but we tried both
get the social and the environmental and
the economic benefits I'll get a little
bit into how we do this there's a whole
branch of economics that tried to do
this and suffice it to say that we work
with some of the best economists in the
world we try to get it right of course
that doesn't mean we get it right
but at least the benefit of trying to do
this is then suddenly you know what the
benefit cost ratio is you know how much
it's gonna cost in terms of dollars you
know how much good it's gonna do in
terms of dollars although there's both
environmental and social and economic
benefits in there and so you know how
much bang are you getting for each buck
you're spending that's the crucial bit
because then suddenly you can start
comparing it across all different areas
and that's what we do so I just came
back from Haiti we're doing a project
where we're prioritizing for the
government of Haiti together with the
Canadian Development Agency to try to
look at what are all the smart things
you can do in Haiti and say where can
you get the most good one of the issues
that they pointed out was this there's a
lack of urban sanitation this is a
terrible picture right that girl should
not be waving through that sort of dirt
right that is surely not good for her
and for everyone else that lives there
this is the kind of picture that makes
you want to donate to this and say I
want to help her I want to help all the
people that are around her I want to
send money to the organization that does
this in Haiti let me try and give you a
sense of how we would think about this
problem of urban sanitation and Haiti we
would try to look at the cost so there's
a number cost the cost is first of all
to buy a pit latrine it's one of the
cheapest ways that you can get basic
sanitation the pit latrine per person
the last 15 years and it costs almost 44
dollars then you also need to empty this
that call every 4.5 years and that cost
$33 if you assume a discount rate and
that's basically just how much is the
interest rate that you have to pay in
this that works out as an annualized
cost about $9 so every year you have to
pay 9 dollars to get this pit latrine
per person per year but surely there's a
lot of good
things here there's 3.7 million people
that are without sanitation in urban
areas in Haiti and that means that over
all in Haiti 3132
persons die from diarrhea surely we can
do something about that so there are
lots of benefits the first one is that
we have fewer deaths but we're not going
to avoid all of the 3132 deaths first of
all we're only looking at this in urban
areas but also when you install a pit
latrine it doesn't mean that all the
fecal matter goes away it only means
that there's less fecal matter in the
the drinking water that you have so you
have less diarrhea but you have not no
diarrhea you have less death but not no
deaths we estimate that there's going to
be 254 fewer deaths per year by this
investment but divide it out over 3.7
million people that means an average
every year you don't lose 9 hours of
your life and if you if you translate
that and typically the translation is 3
times GDP per capita that turns into a
benefit of 2 dollars and 58 cents that
sounds cool but suddenly you have a
sense of order of magnitude and if we've
done our sums right you get a sense of
how much are we actually helping this
girl and everyone else but of course
this is not the only thing we also avoid
disease so we avoid the unpleasantness
of being being sick there's on average
five point seven days that you sit on
the can every year and in Haiti and you
avoid some of that you also avoid some
healthcare savings sorry you avoid some
healthcare costs so that's healthcare
savings you also have productivity gain
because when you're not on the bathroom
when you're not sick you can go and work
and also you get some productivity
benefits in the sense that you have to
go for you don't have to travel as far
in order to be able to go to the
bathroom and then finally you have some
educational benefits if your kid you can
actually go to school instead and you
also have some very tiny environmental
benefits so basically that's about
getting the fecal matter out into the
field and use it as fertilizer that
reduces nitrogen leakage and it
increases yields
overall that sums up to about six
dollars and 88 cents so we're the
annoying guys that say yes this is a
beautiful picture but you also need to
remember that the cost is about nine
dollars the benefit if you include
everything is about seven dollars and
that's why we estimate that every time
you spend a dollar and this if you do it
well you will do 77 cents of good that
does not feel good that does not make us
feel good but that was my entire point
to say this is not about the pretty
pictures it's about making sure that we
do the right thing I'll get back to this
at the very end but let's just remember
this so we're trying to find all the
smart things and there's a lot of smart
things to do in Haiti and that's why we
possibly shouldn't be persuaded by the
picture that makes us want to spend the
money where the best picture is so the
research that I'm going to show you
stems from our attempt of looking at
what are the smartest targets for the
world 2016 2030 so the UN wanted to
replace its Millennium Development Goals
back from 2000 and sorry from 1999 which
covered the first 15 years of the
century they were very very simple
pretty smart they simply said reduce
poverty reduce hunger get all kids in
school reduce child deaths reduce
maternal deaths and get everyone water
and sanitation I've just said that's the
whole thing right there but the problem
was that the UN then wanted to say we
should redo that for 2016 2030 and that
matters because over those 15 years
we're estimating the total development
budget for the world is going to be two
and a half trillion dollars so we're
gonna be spending two and a half
trillion dollars surely we should try to
get it right imagine if we could just
change a tiny bit of that to be spent
better that could be a phenomenal
outcome that's what I'll show you -
what's the end of the talk - tonight
here so what they basically did was they
ended up promising everything to
everyone just to give you a sense the
number of targets and
Millennium Development Goals were 18
targets there were 374 words this time
the world has promised a hundred and
sixty nine targets with four thousand
three hundred and sixty nine words I
promise you if you try to read them
you're gonna fall asleep and and the
techno The Economist's slightly spoofed
them by saying these is a hundred and
sixty nine Commandments and you know
they were say there's a reason why Moses
came down the mountain with ten and not
you know one hundred and sixty nine and
that's important because it tells us
promising everything to everyone all the
time everywhere it's not a real promise
it's assembly it makes us feel good it's
the kind of thing that sounds nice but
if it's not actually gonna do the most
good I'm not sure we're doing the best
thing we can so we try to get all of our
research out to everyone this is the
East African we wrote about all the
smart things you can do everywhere this
was an introductory article then we
wrote about air pollution then we wrote
about biodiversity then we wrote about
climate change does it just because it's
in alphabetical order it wasn't actually
conflict and violence and so on we got
everyone in these areas to talk about
what really works and what's important
but likewise we pre we've presented a
lot of evidence and again you can go to
a web site and see all these this is
just on all the things you can do in
health and and this is all the things
you can do for instance and conflict and
violence and illicit financial flows and
education and science and technology
there's many many more studies so
there's about 1800 pages of period
material from eighty-two economists and
44 sector experts but if you want to get
people to read this of course it doesn't
actually help to say we have 2000 p.m.
ages here of period material would you
please read that Suren and then make an
informed decision and that's why I'm so
happy that all of you should have had
this because this is the short version
of our book we also have this coming out
with Cambridge University Press right
but this is the short version of it it's
just a one pager and that basically
tells you all the smart things to do so
that's what I'm going to show you up
here so you can also see this is
basically the result of one-and-a-half
years work for more than 100 racket
academics and everybody feels a little
bad about the fact that you put it on
one page but that's the beauty of it
right what you see here is all the
interventions and then you basically see
how much bang for the buck do you get
the longer the line the better this
makes it much much simpler for everyone
to have this conversation it'd be very
very surprising if this is entirely true
it's not such that you can just say oh
ok so we just do the world by clicking
sort and Excel and then we're done
that's not what we're saying this is the
economists point of view in this this is
an efficient see conversation remember
for instance there's no distributional
conversation on this so this only tells
you one part but an important part of
the conversation right it's a little bit
when you talk about the the menu it
tells you that what's the price what's
the size but we're the kind of guys that
you know if you look over the menu we'd
be like oh spinach that's really cheap
and it's really good for you right but
that doesn't necessarily mean that
that's what you're gonna buy all the
time you may decide to go with the
caviar but at least now you know that
the price is much much higher so what
I'd like to spend the rest of my time
really here is to walk you through this
and give you a sense of why is selling
things really good and why are some
things not really good and I'm gonna use
the European song contest method here so
I'm gonna start from the back and sort
of build to the to the to the inevitable
conclusion so I'm going to start from
the back so let me just show you some of
the things that are in here and try and
give you a little bit of sense of why so
governance
so basically corruption is a huge
problem we worked with Susan grosse
Ackerman an economist from Yale
University and Mary Hildebrandt from
Harvard and Texas A&M
Susan Rose Ackerman was the first
economist to point out that corruption
probably cost the world at trillion
dollars a year it's a huge problem
unfortunately we don't have any good
solutions and so what they say is huge
problem no solutions and our attempt
would be to say well as long as there
are the huge problems where we have
great solutions then we shouldn't try to
sell
the stuff that doesn't work so that's
why we're saying not that we don't think
this is important but simply that we
don't have great solutions to corruption
so let's not spend our money there one
of the other things poverty your demands
come on as are they saying poverty is
not important no what we're saying is
tackling poverty directly is often a
really bad deal for instance if you try
to get better social provisions so you
know one of the things that a lot of
people want to do is to say let's get
really great job protection rules so
that people are well they have their
minimum wages that they have good job
conditions they have all kinds of things
that's great but remember only for the
people who then get the jobs and the
problem is we've good data for instance
in India and elsewhere that shows if you
make these rules too high you
essentially push a lot of people back
into the informal economy and so it's
great for the people who get the jobs
but it's actually worse for more people
which is why this is probably a bad deal
so again the idea here is not to say of
course we all want to get rid of poverty
but there are actually much much better
ways to get away from poverty and I'll
show that so that's obviously education
that's about getting better job
opportunities for women and specially
opportunities to inherit and run
businesses and of course it's also about
free trade and many many other things so
there are many indirect ways and I'll
get to another great indirect way of
tackling one of the other problems I'll
be talking about later but the
fundamental point is to say don't do
stuff that doesn't work do stuff that
does work and so I'm going to be saying
this quite a bit because we're in the
bottom end of of this water and
sanitation that was what we're talking
about before let me just take a look at
this I mean obviously it's a huge
problem so we know globally that
sanitation for the world sanitation lack
of sanitation kills probably 280,000
people each year but with basic
sanitation we can only help about a
quarter of those people so it's not
going to solve the problem but it is
going to make it better
so we have economists estimate the cost
and of course this is an estimate
because we're going to try and do this
across the entire world the cost is
probably
31 billion dollars a year so substantial
amount given that we are spending about
a hundred and forty billion in total but
the benefits would both be time savings
and that actually turns out from most of
the world to be the most important part
so you get time savings so you can you
don't have to wait in line or if you're
an urban area or go far far out and also
it means that you have less opportunity
for instance for a rape for women and
then of course there's mortality in the
disease part we estimate the total
benefit at about 91 billion dollars and
that's why we get a benefit cost ratio
of about three so it's okay but it's not
phenomenal it's much better than Haiti
mostly because Haiti is incredibly
expensive so everything you do and also
because we're only looking at urban
sanitation and Haiti not rural
sanitation where it's cheaper and hence
probably a better deal so if we move on
air pollution I'll actually get back to
that when we get to energy then climate
change obviously is something that gets
a lot of people's attention so let me
just give a brief sense of why is there
both a pretty bad idea and a pretty good
idea so if you look at climate the
two-degree target our economists set
that as a bad idea
that's not because they're saying it's a
bad idea to try to do something about
global warming but it's that the
two-degree target which actually is not
really well founded and simply there's
been some research that indicates where
does that come from it probably comes
from a research result from the 1980s
about a specific species of plant how
well it could handle temperature rises
on a sea lake but you know who knows the
point is that they say the cost of
achieving the two-degree target is about
a thousand billion dollars or about a
thousand trillion but if you had a
target of just three degree degrees
instead you'd cut off the really
dangerous part but you wouldn't cut as
much off so you would have some damages
but it would also be much much cheaper
so the cost would only be about forty
percent of forty trillion dollars yet
the benefit of going all the way to two
degrees is only tiny bit more so you'll
avoid about a hundred billion dollars in
damages around the end of the century so
you'd essentially
paying sixty trillion dollars now these
are discounted dollars in order to avoid
a fairly small amount of extra damage by
the end of the century that's a bad deal
that's why they're saying well we should
probably go for something like three
degrees they're not committing to three
degrees target they were basically
trying to tell the UN don't do the two
degree target maybe say yeah two point
five or three or three point two or
whatever that number is but that's a
much much harder conversation to have
but don't just say to the other bit
green energy research and development a
phenomenal idea this is what Bill Gates
and many others are pushing for our
research shows that basically there's a
dramatic under investment in green
energy R&D right now
we have been languishing compared to
healthcare and many many others if we
invested about a hundred billion dollars
a year that's a six-fold increase of
what the world was spending now the cost
across the century because you have to
ramp it up would be about sixteen
hundred billion discounted back till
today but the avoided climate damage and
the avoid policy cost would actually be
in the order of eighteen trillion
dollars and that's why we find every
dollar spent would do eleven dollars of
good so again the point here is simply
to say it's not like there's good and
bad policy areas they're good and bad
policies and so one of them the
two-degree target it's probably a bad
idea the dramatically ramped up green
energy R&D is probably a great target
and that's why we have the very small
one the red one and the very long one so
that's really where I want to go and let
me just move on to energy and then we'll
also get back to the to the air
pollution as you can see there's
anything from really bad ones to pretty
good ones up there so let me just again
go through them if you take a look at
what are some of the things you can do
the the UN is very gung-ho on getting
more renewable energy so the target was
at the time we did this they have
actually just made it substantially
increase but at the time we did this
they said it would the target was double
of renewable energy that sounds great
and yes there are lots of benefits we
actually estimated the benefits per year
would be in the order of four hundred
and fifteen billion dollars that's not
primarily for what you think namely that
its climate benefits though there are
some climate benefits
the vast amount of benefits come from
the fact that a lot of poor people have
very little energy access so getting
more energy access is a really really
good idea the problem is that doing this
over the next 15 years is going to be
extraordinarily costly and so we
estimate the total cost there's going to
be about five hundred and fourteen
billion dollars spending 500 billion on
doing four hundred billion dollars worth
of good is not a particularly good idea
yes it does do some good but you're
basically only doing 80 cents back on
the dollar if you look at some of the
other things double energy efficiency we
know from Europe many other places this
is a pretty good idea the costs are
substantial but the benefits are even
more substantial the benefit cost ratio
is about three universal energy access
obviously this would be an amazing thing
but also remember this would be
extraordinarily costly so you know
basically take up the entire development
budget of the world just to achieve that
but again we're not saying that we
should do all of that we were simply
making the sense but the benefit would
also be extraordinarily high and so the
benefit cost ratio would be seven so
this is really just a way of getting our
sense of what works and what doesn't let
me just show you two more things indoor
air pollution it's one of those
incredibly boring things that most
people have never heard of it just
happens to be the world's deadliest
environmental problem yeah when you ask
people what's the most deadly problem
they'll typically say water and
sanitation or global warming or
something like that but it's actually an
order of magnitude off global warming
kills one hundred and forty one thousand
people according to the World Health
Organization water and sanitation
probably kills about four hundred four
hundred and fifty thousand people per
year but indoor air pollution kills four
point three million people it's the one
of the deadliest killers in the world
why that's because almost three billion
people's almost half this world's
population cook and keep warm with dirty
fuels typically wood cardboard dung
whatever they can get their hands on and
that means the indoor of most places in
the third world if you go out in rural
areas the indoor air where a lot of
people live perhaps a third of their
life is
times more polluted than the outdoor of
Beijing how come you only hear about the
Beijing that's of course because that's
where the journalists are that's where
the journalists children are that's
where the good pictures are but
unfortunately the other is actually more
important World Health Organization
estimate it's the equivalent of every
one of these almost three billion people
smoking two packs of cigarettes every
day so not surprisingly yes that's
really really dangerous now how can you
tackle it well the long-term solution is
to make these people rich so you know I
assume nobody here is so poor that you
actually have open fires indoors I mean
that's exactly the point right you don't
do that when you get rich but indoor air
pollution is incredibly important and we
can do something about we can get better
cooking stoves to about 30% of the
world's populations are still going to
be air pollution but slightly less
because it's more efficient they don't
have to spend as much money on wood or
they don't have to spend as much time
collecting the wood and they can also
actually cook faster because it's a more
concentrated heating source so we
estimate the cost is about 11 billion
dollars a year but the benefit is about
a hundred and sixty 1 billion so the
benefit cost ratio is 15 and also get
rid of self you'll subsidies they just
stupid you know in Venezuela for
instance they pay I mean there's a lot
of things that are not right and been so
a little bit but but you know they they
they subsidize gasoline at 92 percent
I'm not actually sure what it's like
this is these numbers a year old and
they yeah who knows but 92 percent that
of course means it's incredibly cheap to
get gasoline but you know it's sold as a
subsidy for poor people but of course
it's not it's mostly a subsidy to rich
people you have to have a car in order
to enjoy it or to really enjoy it and so
it's a subsidy to have people drive too
much and pollute too much and congest
too much so it's a very very good thing
to get rid of it cost 20% of Venezuela's
government expenditure and of course
those could be spent much much better in
health care or education as something
else so that was a big thing on energy
let me just talk a little bit about some
of these others and then I want to move
on to some of the top ones conflict and
violence we didn't do a particularly
good job on how do you tackle conflict
and violence we have some good estimates
but it's actually something where
there's a lot of research lacking but we
did do some studies that showed and we
did the first cost study on violence
against women and children and they're
amazing and sounding and a little very
very depressing so the with UN numbers
we estimate every year 309 million women
are beat by their domestic partner so
bad that it would be a criminal act in
the u.s. we estimate the total cost of
that is four point three trillion
dollars so about five percent of global
GDP that's a huge problem again one
that's very very overlooked and five
percent of GDP is the equivalent loss of
how 309 million women have to suffer
every year also every month not every
year every month 280 million children
are being severely beaten by their
parents so beat so much beaten there
would be a criminal offense in the u.s.
that's a terrible outcome and that's an
incomprehensible really so the point
here is again to remember that if we
could do something about that actually I
should just tell you that out of these
280 million kids that are being beaten
every month a quarter of them the person
that are beating them only stops when
the implement with which they beat them
breaks so and we estimated that caused
three point six trillion dollars for the
world so there's a huge problem here and
a problem that we haven't really seen so
let me just take you through this so if
you look now we were talking about
conflict and violence infrastructure is
right above and infrastructure is
basically the idea of broadband
dramatically increases growth so if you
get more broadband you will also
slightly increase the growth rate and
that's actually a really good deal for
most countries if you look at
biodiversity above that there's a very
surprising thing half coral reef loss
and they'll actually do
twenty-four dollars worth of good so
that's an amazing outcome
so half coral reef loss is an amazing
outcome why well partly is it is we're
only we're setting ourselves a fairly
limited target we're not saying get back
all coral reefs we're saying there is
going to be loss of coral reefs but we
can reduce that loss by half because
half of what's going to be loss of the
next 15 years is something that's very
easily manageable it's basically
stopping people dynamite fishing and
cyanide fishing that's obviously very
bad for the reef and it's not all that
great for the fisherman but if you do
that not only will you get biodiversity
benefits but you'll also get benefits in
some other ways you'll get benefits in
the sense of if you have a healthy reef
they produce more fish and that means
that you get more fisheries that's great
for fishermen all across the world so
doesn't that's really really useful and
then you also get more tourism so when
you add up all those benefits you not
only get more biodiversity you get more
fish so that's food for kids and you
also get more tourism so that's higher
income all of that added up because it's
also very cheap you do twenty four
dollars worth of good the Santos the
president Colombia is very enthusiastic
about this whole process and he's
mentioned this a bunch of times when
they started making new marine resources
so you know again it's something that's
been used in real policy if you take a
look at education we find typically and
a little depressingly right because I am
assuming almost everyone in here really
well-educated so we all tend to believe
that the answer to anything has to be
more education right but the reality is
that it's really hard typically to
convert money into better educational
outcomes it's very easy to waste it but
it's really hard to actually do it well
and that's why we find typically that
most educational impacts are not all
that great but one stands out and that's
preschool in sub-saharan Africa there's
almost no preschool there's only about
20% preschool we're talking about
tripling that to about 60% that would be
a phenomenal impact why is that so much
better well partly preschool is much
cheaper you
have cheaper teachers you're going to
more kids in the class and then you also
get a longer time frame on which it
works on these kids so you can actually
have more years of benefit that comes in
and what happens when you get preschool
is very often that you end up with
generating a lifelong journey to learn
so that these kids later on the lives
will take one or two years more than
they otherwise would have done and hence
become much more productive but I want
to talk about food right after because
that's actually a surprising solution to
the educational issue why is that
well nutrition is obviously crucially
important in many ways but there's
another way that this turns out to be
much much more important we know that if
you get good nutrition to small kids
there are two two-year-olds that means
that their brains develop more so that
when they go to school they learn more
and so the theory was when they come out
they'll be more productive that's how
economists evaluate the benefit of
Education but now we actually know
because there's an amazing study that
was done in Guatemala it started back in
the 1960s so in 1960 some researchers
went down to Guatemala they found two
small two small rural villages and fed
the kids there well and they found two
other small rural villages nearby and
you can kind of hear where this is going
right they fed the kids really badly
this is the 60s you could get away with
that right they gave them sugar water
but the amazing thing is our research
has now gone down and refound those kids
they're now in their late 30s early 40s
they refined about 2,000 kids are well
fed and about 1,500 that weren't amazing
difference on almost all accounts and
this is pretty much a control experiment
right they have better lives they're
better marriages they have fewer kids if
they're women they're humans characters
but crucially the theory that we had was
that they'd be better able to go to
school and that was indeed what happened
they had longer school they'd learnt
more during each one of those years and
if they had avoid it becoming stunted
which is a
way of indicating that your that you're
a malnourished if they avoided being
stunned it they had on average 60%
higher wages phenomenal change of course
this goes on they'll now bring up their
own kids better and hence make sure that
they are better fed they have better
school and start this virtuous circle so
what we find is instead of when you talk
about education people typically say ah
there's a school and there's the teacher
and you think how what can you do about
the school it turns out you can do very
little Indonesia in the 1990s doubled
the number of schools in a decade
doubled them and the difference was the
impact the outcome was that they
increased attendance by one percentage
point yes a lot of kids now don't have
to walk as far to their school that's
probably good but it was really really
tiny most of the impacts that we do in
schools turn out to be very useless
likewise if you spend money on teachers
it turns out to be really really hard to
get teachers to teach better by just
giving more money but we often forget
that there's a third component right the
student if you make the students smarter
and we can do that with food then you
can actually make a dramatic outcome so
what we did for Guatemala we found the
average cost and this is for the world
is ninety seven dollars to feed a kid
two years well that's reasonable this is
we're including distributional cost and
the benefit is that they on average get
higher wages if you discount that over
their entire lifetime the average
benefit is four thousand three hundred
and sixty-five dollars so that's why
every dollar spent will do forty five
dollars worth of good that's why this is
such an amazing outcome because we have
a better way to tackle schooling so you
know counter-intuitively we say if you
want to help schooling don't look at
schools because that's really hard
typically try it don't look at teachers
because that's really hard but there's a
phenomenally easy first way to do that
and we invest a lot more in nutrition
for kids so let me move on and look at
health there's as you can see lots of
health we work with Dean Jamison from
the universe
Washington who has written the book
together with a lot of other researchers
on disease control priorities for the
World Health Organization and these are
just some of the many many many things
they've looked at I'm just gonna look at
one thing tuberculosis because
tuberculosis is the world's leading
killer now infectious disease killer
it's not HIV it's not malaria is
tuberculosis yet HIV has much much
better press in so many different ways
so we estimate actually HIV probably
takes up about 25% of the health budget
whereas tuberculosis only gets 4%
tuberculosis is boring right every time
I write an op-ed and try to get it into
paper people could you write something
about climate instead and and you know
it's just depressing that that's the way
it is but of course what we have to say
is this is actually a really really good
intervention so again bear with me
because I'm just gonna show you a little
bit how we do this there's a lot of
latent tuberculosis so things we don't
know and the so we when we do screening
for all the people who didn't know that
they had tuberculosis it cost about
$1600 for every case found and we'll end
up with about 2.7 million cases and that
will cost four point three billion
dollars then we can treat the vast
number of people who have TB who knows
it comes to get a test and then get drug
that cost about three hundred and eighty
seven dollars only about four hundred
dollars and there's almost six million
cases that turns out to be about 2.2
billion dollars then they see multi
drug-resistant which of course you also
have to treat although that's much much
more costly so that's all more than
$3,000 per case but fortunately there's
many fewer cases there's about half a
million all of that turns into about 9
million cases each year that we can
treat and that's one point
eight sorry one point eight million
deaths so the total cost is about eight
billion dollars annually about $900 per
TB case averted the benefit is these
people on average live 20 years longer
again we estimate the value of each of
these at $3,000 per disability adjusted
life year basically per life here avoid
it so that turns out to the median
benefit is about 40
thousand dollars at a cost of nine
hundred dollars that's why we get the
benefit cost ratio at forty three again
an amazing investment and one that we
should be doing much more so as you've
seen these we looked at the health I'm
just going to show you two other things
then and then I'll move to the final
sort of observation zone we'll get to
your questions if you look at gender we
find that Family Planning turns out to
be a phenomenal investment so there's
two hundred and fifteen million women
who still don't have access to
contraception there's a lot of women who
don't have access to this to achieve to
get that will cost about three point six
billion dollars to get access but the
benefits will be multiple first of all
we know that there will be fewer kids
dying that's basically because you can
space your kids better if you have
contraception you don't have to have
them right when it's harvest rings what
we know that there's a much higher
mortality rate for children it also
means that fewer moms are gonna die
about a hundred and fifty thousand fewer
moms and we also have about six hundred
thousand kids we're not gonna lose their
moms that we didn't actually price
because we don't know how to price it
and that's one of the things that you
could say and you can say this in a lot
of different cases if anything some of
these numbers are probably under
estimates that in total adds up to about
one hundred and forty five billion
dollars a year in benefits but that's
not the only thing because when you get
fewer kids and you have more productive
moms that means that you end up with
fewer dependents pure young dependents
you still have few old dependents you
have more people in the working age that
means you have higher economic growth
that's what's known as the demographic
dividend that was what China essentially
did in a very sort of on steroids kind
of way when they only had a one-child
policy you grow enormously because
everybody is working we estimate that
Democratic demographic dividend at about
300 billion on so in total the benefit
will be about four hundred and thirty
billion dollars at a cost of just three
point six billion dollars and that's why
we find getting conscious
to women all the women who don't have it
would probably generate a hundred and
twenty dollars worth of good for every
dollar you spend that's a phenomenal
outcome that's definitely something we
ought to be doing the last bit
sorry I just before before we move on I
just want to you know if you look at the
gender sorry I can't make it go down but
if you look at the reduced child
marriages on the other hand that yeah
that amazes a lot of people they're like
what we're saying that's a bad idea to
reduce child married do you like child
marriage that's not what we're saying
right we're simply trying to point out
that although it's a very very worthy
goal to want to reduce child marriages
but just saying we want to reduce them
doesn't typically work there's been lots
and lots of efforts in trying to
criminalize it's a criminalized almost
everywhere and it still happens Lots and
to get information out to people and say
you know you should really not marry off
your daughter and people like really
they they know the social customs much
better it's not about trying to stop
that directly it's about the indirect
route so getting better education for
women getting better opportunities for
women to work and to inherit and to
participate also politically so that
it's a lot of indirect ways that will
make it more worthwhile for these kids
and especially for these women to be
able to stay in school instead of
getting married but the direct route
just simply trying to work on reducing
child marriages almost invariably fails
and that's why we end up saying that
that's a bad deal
the last bit I just want to talk about
is trade so trade a successful Doha
turns out to be a phenomenally good
investment again what we find is if you
look at what's the cost to go around
well to get I mean most people have
forgotten we were trying to negotiate it
Doha round but if you run the models the
cost of doing this well it's hard to say
it's not just the bureaucrats it's
clearly something else that's making a
lot of people not wanting to have this
free treat trade deal we've estimated
that at the cost of keeping the Western
farmers happy because they're typically
in historically been the ones I've been
trying to avoid having a free trade
round succeed so basically paying off
more Western farmers with more money so
250 billion dollars but the benefits of
phenomenal not only if you do the
standard static models from World Bank
we find that the benefit that's
basically the benefit from you can
produce something and I can produce
something else and if we trade we get a
little richer because we both better off
because you're better at doing one thing
and I'm better at doing something else
that's the static benefit that's about a
hundred hundred and fifty billion
dollars but there's also a dynamic
benefit and we've seen in almost all
countries if you start opening up your
trade you get more competition you get
more skills you get more ability you
don't have to reinvent the wheel all the
time so overall you end up having a
higher growth rate and if you
incorporate that the global models from
the World Bank indicate that we would
get on the order over the next 15 years
on the order of five hundred thousand
billion dollars richer we thought you
being the Nerds we were we thought this
was just a really cool number to show
the journalist it turns out that that's
just too many zeros so they had no idea
what we were saying there is sort of
glaze over so we we tried to say eleven
trillion dollars that worked a little
better per year in 2030 even better and
even clearer this means on average the
average person in the developing world
in 2030 will be 1,000 dollars richer
that's an amazing outcome and that of
course means will lift out a lot of
people who estimated about a hundred and
sixty million people will be lifted out
of poverty extra from where we're
already expecting that there will be
fewer people in poverty in 2030 but will
lift another hundred and sixty million
people out of poverty and that's why we
say if you spend two hundred and fifty
billion dollars but you get five hundred
thousand billion dollars back you've
done two thousand dollars back in the
dollar that's a really good deal again
it's unclear if could you go out and get
that deal no probably not because it's a
you know it's it's a little bit like
building a bridge it doesn't help you
build half of it right you really need
to get all the way but if we could get
our world leaders to think about that
and I realize you guys have a problem
with that right now
but making this point would make it
easier right and that's really what this
is about
that's why we do these that's why we do
this overview right we basically try to
make this easy for people to see where
can you do a lot of good and where can't
you this is not the same thing as saying
pick the spinach and pick the spinach
every time right but it's about getting
people to move up to do more of the
really smart stuff so let me just show
you what we found for the United Nations
for the SDG sustainable development
goals this is sort of our money graph
but it takes a little bit of showing so
I'm just gonna walk you through it there
was a hundred and sixty nine targets so
if we did all hundred and 69 and
remember this is a back-of-the-envelope
and I don't think there's any other way
to do it
so we're estimating what if you spent a
dollar across all hundred and sixty nine
targets equally and that may not make
entirely sense pretty good because some
of them you can fill up what much
quicker than others but bear with me it
gives you sort of the blunt the the the
the the the thrust of the argument so if
we had 169 targets here we estimate on
average if you spent a dollar across all
169 targets you would then do about
seven dollars worth of good that's
actually pretty good you'll end up doing
seven dollars of good for every dollar
spent
but of course remember this requires you
to do all the right things and do it all
the right way but it's really carried
through by a few targets that are
phenomenally good then there's a lot of
targets that are sort of so-so and then
there's some targets are actually bad
but if you do it across all of them
you'll end up with seven dollars per
dollar spent but notice what happens if
you cut it back I put all of their or
the targets ordered by efficiency so if
you go down and say instead of having 50
targets try and just have 40 targets
sorry instead of have a hundred and 69
target try just to have 40 targets what
happens then then for every dollar spent
you'll do 21 dollars worth of good you
will just have tripled the amount of
good you do for every dollar and
remember we're talking about two and a
half
trillion dollars that's pretty cool if
you can triple that right what we
actually ended up saying was no you
should just do 19 specific targets and
you can go on our websites to look at
what those are but it's basically the
most effective ones that we've been
going through if you did that
we estimate every dollar spent would do
32 dollars worth of good you'd more than
quadruple the benefit of what the world
would be doing so again let me just put
this in context if we're gonna be
spending two and a half trillion dollars
per year sorry over the next 15 years we
estimate the seven dollars back under
all this we'll do 17 and a half trillion
dollars of good that's great thank you
world you really helped but if we'd
spend it in the best possible way we
could end up do 80 trillion dollars of
social good we could do 60 2.5 trillion
dollars more good and that's where I
mean you and us all of us can try to
make our policy leaders spend the money
such that we could do much much more
good than even Bill Gates would do every
year the world spends about 200 billion
dollars to do good
that's about 135 from public spending
and about 65 from philanthropy spending
so about 200 billion dollars this might
do at $7 again 1.4 trillion dollars
worth of good if we did it smartest we
could do six point four trillion dollars
worth of good we could have done five
trillion dollars better every year
but the real crux here is to say that's
not gonna happen right we're not
magically suddenly gonna make everyone
rational there's all kinds of reasons
why we do the wrong thing that picture
of the girl from Haiti you remember
that's one of them and there's many many
many reasons but by making this argument
by having this conversation by showing
this evidence that there's some places
where you can just do a little good and
there are some places where you can do
amazing amounts of good we can push
people a little bit we can give tailwind
to all the good ideas and we can give
headwind to the bad ones right so I'm
simply making the very simple argument
I'm saying if we could change just 1% of
the spending that the world do both from
USAID and from all the others in the
other countries and from all the
philanthropist from Bill Gates and
onwards if we could change that just 1%
from being just sort of mediocre to
being amazing we could do 50 billion
dollars of social good each and every
year and that's the real power of this
argument that's what I'm hoping and
that's what all of people that I work
with is hoping so please bring this
along and you know discuss it with all
your friends and I showed this to to
Mike Bloomberg at one point and and he
was like oh yeah I went through it with
my with my pencil and wrote all the
stuff that we spend money on and I said
it back to my research department ask
them why we aren't spending more in the
long lines I was like wait this is
exactly the kind of conversation we're
gonna and of course they're not gonna
suddenly just spend on the really long
line but possibly they're gonna do a
little more good so when you see this
picture remember that yes I want to give
money to her but we have to remember
that she's not the only one we're trying
to help we're not just trying to help
the ones that got photographed and we're
not just trying to help her in the way
that she's being photographed so yes if
we prioritize we may actually end up in
a situation where she might not get
clean water first but if we prioritize
she'll get so many other things she'll
get better nutrition she'll get better
school she'll get better health she'll
get safer birth she'll get higher income
less violence hopefully she'll get less
air pollution more energy and more
rights and that's really what we have to
remember this is not about doing what
feels good this really is about making
sure that we do the smart nerdy things
yes but the things I'll actually help
end up helping both her and everyone
else in the best possible way thank you
[Applause]
all right for xandred a lot of great
questions got me sitting through a lot
of them so we'll start with the one
which just come up in many different
forms which is what's the discount rate
you're working on for all this bling out
these yes cost benefits over time so we
work with two discount rates a low and a
high so we work with 3% and 5% and you
can see all of the material on the
website when I show you this I'm
basically showing you the median of it
so it's like 4% we should also just
remember this is very much a first-world
discount rate when we went to Bangladesh
which is where we've done our first
project they were late what 3% 5% and
they ended up wanting 10% now we're
doing the study in Haiti and they were
like 10% they wanted 20% which basically
means you don't care about stuff after
hearing but you know if you know Haiti
that's pops not a totally unrealistic
expectation explanation of how Haiti
works we ended up using a 12% so we use
the three five and ten in Bangladesh or
twelve in Haiti how does this affect
some of the question includes is some of
the really longer-term issues like
climate change which really plays out
over many decades whereas many of the
things you're looking at or pretty
immediate problems with immediate
solutions yes so it's very clear that
this would shift you know the higher the
discount rate so basically for the
people who don't know what discount rate
is it's basically a way to prioritize
how you to to waive how you prioritize
the present versus the future so if you
have a high discount rate you mostly
care about the present if you have a low
discount rate you more care about the
future and less about the the current
issues so what we do is we do both the
three and the five percent I think there
are very few people that would argue to
have something substantially under three
percent and likewise there's very many
actually that would argue should have
something above five
most finance ministries have 7% or even
nine or eight percent so if anything
we're skewed slightly to its lower end
so in that sense we're probably if
anything overestimating the benefit cost
ratio of climate you need to go down to
like 1% of something to for instance
make some of those you know the current
sort of proposals that we're doing in
climate work out I wonder how that ten
thousand year time frame works out yes
yes 0 percent is the only number that
you can sort of work that that is
entirely right but then you know
economists would tend to say and I think
that has some validity that if you have
a discount rate of 0% or very close to
Sarah that basically means you only care
about the future and so you know if you
look they did some studies for instance
on Nicholas turn did a review of the
economics of his climate where he used a
0.1% and that turns into meaning that
you need to spend ninety seven point
five percent of your income for the
future that basically means I'm just
gonna eat porridge and I'm gonna leave
everything to the future the problem
with that argument is two things partly
that that's what the next generation is
going to do too right so that's a lot of
porch and a lot of money for the for the
future when they're going to be much
much better off but the second thing is
we don't act that way you know in most
most countries most people spend about
15% on the future which is much more
equivalent to five or even higher and
that means basically most of us by our
actions show that we say we care a
little bit about the future but not all
that much well so when you look at
solution space as technology gets better
and various other things Communications
get better cellphones get distributed in
the Sun presumably the costs of
solutions as you guess at them now will
probably keep coming down is that your
experience you've been looking based for
how long now for 12 years hmm that would
probably be true but I don't think it's
a it's a totally general position the
other thing I'd say is also and and
obviously you know as you might imagine
we're trying to square the circle
between a lot of different disciplines
and they all work on slightly different
approaches so we try to standardize as
as we can we have the same value of life
the same discount rate the same growth
expectancies and all these different
things but honestly they they each leave
out different things and we try to get
them to qualitatively s/s how much that
is but one big thing that they leave out
is when we talk to climate people and
education people because they are the
ones that are used to having long
discount rates yeah you invest in the
education you really only get the
benefit in 20 30 40 50 years so they
know this but if you talk to doctors
they don't care about 20 or 50 years
down the line because they're like hey
there's so many bodies on the table
after 10 years so they pretty much stop
after that and so one of the things that
we I would very much like to see and my
suspect is true but I don't know because
we can't get them to do it is if you
lowered the benefit-cost sorry if you
lowered the discount rate you'd get
climate would be better education would
be better but chances are that
tuberculosis and everything else would
also be bigger better because suddenly
you get many many more people not dying
and hence you would make sure that they
would be richer so that they would not
have their kids dying and so you get
these dramatic generational thanks that
we're totally missing right now because
the doctors are like cutting it off
after ten years there you go well you
you are pointing out that sort of
generalizing ferociously and you need to
in order to get these comparative
numbers and yet as I gather you've done
work now you're doing or currently in
Haiti and have done work recently in
Bangladesh you spell a little bit about
what you were telling me earlier work in
Haiti means what city you actually been
doing there yeah so so you know when you
do this globally
I think it's intellectually interesting
what's the world's biggest issues where
should we be focusing our money but
everybody when we present it to them
they're like I don't live in the world
and yes you do but yeah in some ways you
we always feel like well that might be
true because somewhere else you know so
if you show this in India they say oh
that China if you show in China they say
oh that's Latin America or something
else
so in some sense doing this in
individual nations is much much more
relevant for these nations so in Haiti
we're working with everyone so from
government to
to civil society to academics and and to
to the NGOs and we asked them in all
these different areas what are the
important issues in Haiti so one of the
things that came up was I had no idea
lots and lots of people died in
accidents it's a really dangerous
country about every xx s is due to
accidents and so the Haitians want to
have an ambulance service there's almost
no ambulances so they want a national
ambulance service so our economists at
that and they looked at it yes it's very
expensive to get so many ambulances that
you can get out everywhere in Haiti but
it's also really good because you'll
actually start saving people's lives so
we estimated that getting ambulances
everywhere would probably do $3 back in
the dollar that's pretty good
but then we also looked at what happens
if you only do this in urban areas
because it's really hard to get all
these ambulances out in rural areas if
you save it only in urban areas you can
cut down the number of ambulances by 75%
and you can still save the vast majority
of the people so suddenly the benefit
cost ratio is 8 that's much better but
then they also said what about how about
you know cutting away the ambulances
because there's so many people dying
what you really need is paramedics and
the real big cost is the ambulances what
if you just had the paramedics then the
bang for the buck is 16 again remember
there's some distributional issues here
if you're out in the countryside you'll
feel screwed about this right of course
we would argue that there's probably
other things people in the countries I
would rather have than ambulances but
the whole point here is to start having
that conversation and by getting these
numbers you can really get a sense of
difference so we've done a similar one
where we haven't we're still publishing
and in Haiti but we've done this for
Bangladesh and we've gotten this in the
hands of pretty much everyone in
Bangladesh it's mostly made by
Bangladeshi economists and I was
surprised by some of the things that
that are different actually and I can I
just say this one thing we found one
great solution for corruption which I
was really pleased so it's really hard
to find good solutions for corruption
globally but we found this one for
Bangladesh Bangladesh spends a lot of
money like most developing countries on
procure
so they spent about a third of their
government budget on procurement you
know anything from post-it notes to
roads but because roads are so much more
expensive is mostly infrastructure so
that's is that seven billion dollars to
spend every year and it's hugely corrupt
so they have this leftover from British
rule that you come you have to hand in a
sealed bid a sealed envelope in a
specific government office but of course
yeah in the local corruption they've
already decided out there you're gonna
get the bid and what they do is they
just put up goons outside that office so
you can't physically come in with your
bid right boom you got the bid so what
we tried to do was to say what if you
could have a procurement so we actually
our researcher convinced the Bangladeshi
government you have a German electronic
online did online yes essentially eBay
right procurement so we took 4% of
Bangladesh procurement online for two
years and looked at how much cheaper can
we get it not only do you get better
quality you can get everyone to bid from
all over Bangladesh but the price
decreased by almost 12% now there's
probably still corruption but there's 12
percent less corruption that's amazing
that's basically 700 million dollars for
free in Bangladesh not surprisingly the
finance minister of Bangladesh think
we're wonderful yeah and so their
instance doing this now and in the next
year and a half sure it would have
happened eventually but by pointing out
that this is a really really good
investment
they simply adopted it faster so since
you've now had the experience of
comparing differences in Bangladesh and
in Haiti what kind of things sort of
turnout is significant differences in
those quite different places I think
they're both developing world yes
they're both famously desperate and yet
they're different yes I think the big
difference is that people have different
conversations about what are their
solutions so we find very clearly you
know vaccines or immunization nutrition
so free trade energy is good some of
these other things they're they're
always good but then you know in in
Bangladesh you want to talk about
ready-made garment that's where they've
made most of their their money
they want to talk about you know what do
we do about child marriages some of
these other things that are very big in
Bangladesh there were also some things
they didn't want to talk about for
instance to Eric you'll assess every
eleventh death in Bangladesh is due to
tuberculosis every eleventh death yet
most of the elite believe that they had
fixed it because they have a great
health care system so if you get into
the health care system you get diagnosed
you get treated and you survive but a
lot of people don't go into the health
care system because there's a lot of
stigma and you lose your income for
about a year because you're sick and so
you know most people that are poorer
will you know when they start coughing
they'll just hope it goes away which it
does because you die so the problem is
that if you could avoid that and we have
some ways to do that you can actually
dramatically reduce and make life much
better many places and that was one of
the things so Bangladesh and now set
aside more money for health care but
there are other things like for instance
ambulances that I would never have
dreamt on Haiti also has a big issue of
civil civic education they've had a lot
of coos they have had a lot of sense
there's a lack of sense of cohesion in
in in in Haiti and so by getting a
civics course everywhere they they have
the idea that maybe this will make them
much better also it's been a big part of
the conversation and we've done a
cost-benefit I can't tell you right now
what its what it is but you know it'll
help make that conversation there's also
they want an army they and again I'm not
going to get into that at all but they
don't have an army they feel like they
should have an army it's a big thing in
in Haiti and so we're trying to make
cost-benefit analysis and that some
specific things change harvest and ask
can a well run micro banking scheme
lived poor out of poverty we hear a lot
about that yes so so microfinance was a
big thing especially it came from
Bangladesh we work together with brac
who's the originators of brac is the
world's biggest NGO they have a hundred
and ten thousand employees they
basically can't Anglin very big yes and
they they do a lot of basic services in
Bangladesh and yet when you look at the
Quran demise controlled trial studies
they showed that the
strip benefit for more microfinance is
not all that high now remember we are
only looking at the marginal change
we're not looking at is it a good idea
that what we already have done because
we've already done it we're using the
policy relevant question of saying if
you were gonna spend an extra dollar an
extra billion dollars so the next
spending and that's the right one
because that's what we're actually
thinking about whether we should be
doing and that turns out to be not all
that great unfortunately and this is
backed up by a lot of studies from from
the randomized control trials so we
probably you know taken up we've already
plucked all the low-hanging fruit and by
now it's just sort of a medium range so
there's things going on in the
developing world like urbanization as
urbanization sort of turnout in your
research is something to slow down to
encourage to just prepare for or what
yeah we looked at it the UN was also
looking at it's really really hard to
both say there's there's not that much
great research on it and certainly what
most of them say is that there's very
very little you can do about it you know
it's very hard fundamentally that's
interesting what fundamentally what you
can do is to make sure that you a better
planning for instance firm so you don't
get the sort of very unorganized slums
and this is you know I'm just talking
about sort of from China and everybody
else over hate but but fundamentally
it's it's very hard to see how you can
spend money and make this particular
issue go away if you will obviously some
of the things that we're advocating for
for instance high productivity in the
agricultural sector which would be great
for a country would actually make
urbanization worse because you'd have
fewer people wanting to work in and the
in agriculture and things like
cellphones which seem to have helped
enormously and are sort of self
generating in a way and maybe there's
really not that much to add from a
philanthropic point of view or an aide
point of view but is there is that the
kind of thing that's worth supporting or
so we just we did some studies there's
one I loved you the idea of text
messages for farmers where you being
told now the weather is good to plant
this was this this kind of
a product what is it called this crop
thank you and and and you know some of
those kinds of in and now is a good time
to harvest and all that stuff turns out
to not be very good it's not terrible
but it's like a dollar twenty-five or
something but if you look at the basic
benefit on broadband that probably is
good partly because we know that it
generates economic growth but also
because it enables to have a lot of a
lot of government services online and
that means you know one of the things
that you're lacking much of the
developing world is just a birth
certificate just knowing that you you
know you have rights that you have
abilities and if you're online it's much
easy to get the birth certificate you
know then you can actually you know just
go to a local kiosk and get it instead
of you having to good you know go to a
regional center and wait in three days
that kind of thing it's just related to
the question of like having an ID so you
can get bank loans and yes like this yep
and then it sound like in Bangladesh
there was issues of where the property
lines are and who actually owns right so
Bank Bangladesh has a huge problem
obviously it's a very very crowded
country it's a I I'm sorry I still
haven't found the American State so I
can't give you this but it's three times
the size of Denmark and we're a small
country and we have five million people
in our country Bangladesh has a hundred
and sixty million people so as you might
imagine they're very very tightly packed
they're the they're the most populated
densely populated country in the world
apart from city-states like Singapore
and stuff so land is at a premium they
have this old system back from the from
the English where they write up all
carefully all the land deeds in five
different books so one burns and you
still have the other four but the
problem of course is that's back from
the time of the British who since then
that's diverged so so now you know these
five books tell five different very
different stories we don't quite know
but people estimate that there's
probably about ten times as much land in
the books as an Bangladesh
which is not a good outcome that
basically means if you're rich you can
afford to send people to all five books
and get your deed right but if you're
not you have no idea whether you really
own the land and so you don't really
dare to try to find out because there's
a good chance you're gonna find out I
didn't own and so you under invest in
your land and you have a harder time
using as collateral for loans do you
think that can get Circuit sorted out
with a basically online database and
plenty of bandwidth and is a smart guy
yes this and that was what the the
economists looked at they said you know
basically we should digitize us there's
good when you digitize it there's gonna
be a lot of court cases because
everybody's gonna realize they didn't
own what they thought but afterwards
you're gonna get much higher growth not
much high growth but somewhat better
growth and so we actually find that this
is a really good investment and again
the finance minister it was obvious to
do the e-procurement because that's just
more money for very very little input
but this actually sustained a whole
class of people who are probably getting
a lot of small bribes from everyone so
this is gonna be very very controversial
but he actually said he was gonna get
rid of it in two years so digitize the
whole thing into you there's a lot of
you know pronouncements it doesn't mean
it's gonna happen but again it's very
likely that it's gonna happen more and
again that's simply because you can
suddenly see and because you have that
conversation hey this is a smart thing
to do
do you get you know in one country like
Bangladesh does something like that gets
things sorted out are the other
developing countries paying attention to
things that work like that probably way
too little but I don't know I don't know
the right answer to that my sense is you
know again we've tried to make this
stories elsewhere and there's been some
interest but I think you know in in that
way you know in the in the in the idea
of space we probably have to reinvent
the wheel all the time over and over
again it's done locally then you
mentioned it it's hard to go at poverty
directly so Alex Whistler asking you say
something about the experiment in Africa
I'm just paying everybody in the village
with with money to see what yeah yeah
that's a very very popular thing and
again I would say it's a little bit like
this it's not a picture but it feels
right to a lot of people who spend
here in the and in Silicon Valley kind
of thing there's a lot of people who are
very enthusiastic about it unfortunately
if you look at the randomized control
trial studies it doesn't actually do
very much good so you know not
surprisingly the value of a dollar is
about a dollar so so yeah when you give
it all away hey these guys got a dollar
that's great BC r1 but yes but the
problem is that you could have spent
that on Immunization and basically done
you know $60 worth of good so contrary
to what a lot of people would like this
to be that's again one of those places
where we're knowing and saying yeah no
probably not so a question from Charles
Frandsen what do you think of giveWell
and other organizations that allocate
donation into portfolios and nonprofits
based upon their bang for your buck type
of analysis well I mean first of all I
think they're wonderful that's obviously
what you should do and they do something
else that we don't do they look at how
can you actually get this done right so
they look at the actual organizations
that are doing that we're just simply
saying tuberculosis is a good thing to
spend money on but obviously there's a
whole implementation conversation how do
you do this so in some sense you could
say our primary target is actually you
know USAID and divot and also the gates
of the world who are spending their
money directly
so give well and others are basically
telling all the rest of us how should
you spend your next hundred dollars or
whatever you're gonna write your check
on so somebody who wants to actually
start doing that doing what they see in
your list would do well with something
like it well I think so are there others
in that category I don't know that well
enough and I should also just make that
you know I think in general they give
well ideas good I haven't looked at them
that hard that I know you know I can't
vouch for their for it seems like what
they're doing is really good give it a
try and report back art has a question
is there discrepancies between your
rankings and other entities that do
similar type of rankings
who's your competition and yeah good you
would imagine that there were other
people doing those right but the honest
answer is I don't know of anyone else
and and that you know back when I when I
first started this it just happened
because I made a comparison between two
different things
two different ways that we spend money
and I was like oh how does the meat
comparison but surely you know that's
not the only two things you should
compare acai I want it to look up who
else does you know what is the ranking
of the world and surprisingly there's
nobody who's done this and and still
after we've done this for 13 years
there's still no one else that do this
ranking well you have these meetings in
these gatherings of economists and so
others sort through these things so are
they being influenced by this framing to
do more of what they do normally in this
kind of approach to things they're not
the only guy doing this analysis okay
okay you work with okay yes so we work
with 300 of the world's smartest
economists we work with seven Nobel
laureates and economics you can see them
all on our website so fundamentally when
we go out and talk to people and you
know so we typically sort of Scout out
an area and talk to you know some of the
people there and we very quickly end up
with like everyone say these are the
three best people and then we ask them
and you know one of them can't do it
because they have you know they have too
much other stuff in their plate and then
one of the others say yes but typically
almost everyone wants to do this why
because you know as an academic you love
doing your work but you'd also like
someone to listen to it and very rarely
that happens but what we're good at is
basically to make sure that the the
piece you write for us will be hurt by
very very many people and also a lot of
influences so and but I guess I'm asking
about the influence on the influencers
yes you know these characters come
together they think in these terms they
do the analysis or surprised by some
stuff does that change how they do what
they do in the world yes sorry does it
change the Economist or does it change
the politician does it change the
economists does it oh well I mean again
I
I mentioned James Dean Jamison who works
for University of Washington who's done
the deceased priorities brought a
control project for the World Health
Organization for now 15 years and he was
very kind last time we met at Harvard
and and basically said he thinks is one
of the is probably the most worthwhile
thing he's done in his life so you know
I would imagine but you know I think
that's better to ask them but my sense
is you know most economists think this
is obviously the kind of thing that you
do when I tried to do the first code
making consensus the first
prioritization I talked to a lot of
people and they were all like oh that
sounds like a great idea never gonna
happen
so you know the sense was this is
something somebody ought to do but it's
just too hard to do so now I'm looking
for the BCR of your operation what what
kind of funding are you working with
where is it coming from and then how
does it get out to the world so
obviously we've also done that for
ourselves so I'm really bout you ask all
the right questions so so so
fundamentally we get our funding we used
to get our funding from the Danish
government and now we get it from
typically from organizations so the the
Bangladesh was funded almost exclusively
by the CNA foundation there you probably
don't know them they're cheap clothing
retailers in Europe a little bit like
H&M I know I shouldn't say anything so
how much was there but they they
basically get their their clothes a lot
of their clothings sewn in Bangladesh
they spend as I understand about 50
million dollars in Bangladesh every year
and they felt like they would like some
better sort of direction for where they
would be spending their money but the
but the good thing about this and now I
sound like commercial but it is just for
30 seconds right the good thing is that
this doesn't just help them spend their
fifty million dollars better but you
know Bangladesh spends thirty billion
dollars every year and if you could just
change a little bit of that and we did
it with the international community
spends about three billion dollars but
you can change a little bit of that I'm
not
sure we we change that then you can
really make a huge difference so you
know if you look at what we did with the
with the e-procurement in Bangladesh
just that and if you just assume that we
you know we put a few years forward
we basically estimate that we our
project cost two and a half million
dollars in total for that whole project
so that was a cause that was the cost
and the benefit is in several billions
of dollars for Bangladesh just for that
one thing and we estimate that there's
probably a lot more thing so that's a
very very low ball estimate so you know
a thousand dollars back on the dollar or
more
okay MBC aren't a thousand way to go and
so that incurred winding up here at good
finishing question I think it's Brian
Schulman asks what are the tangible
benefits of your work so far and this is
looking you know across the board the
assessments that Development Goals and
notable partnerships large allocations
from donors the kind of thing that you
just mentioned in Bangladesh what are
you seeing topi errs on doing this stuff
what's happening in the world as a
result of it well you know clearly Trump
isn't taking the advice right I mean the
two top things this free trade America
okay and contraception for women and you
know but again you know there's a lot of
other things that happen beside us we're
you know we're a small academic outfit I
doubt that we're you know we're suddenly
a magically gonna change the whole world
I think two things that we've taken away
the Burg said a nice thing oh god yes
yes it's kinda nice I'm still looking
forward to see him change all his
priorities but you know but you know
we'll see about that
but you've appraised the Gates
Foundation do they praise you I think so
okay yeah I mean they certainly work
with us so that but you know but
fundamentally I think I think we've
learnt two things one is that I was very
sort of enthusiastic about the global
thing because I think that
intellectually makes a lot of sense for
me but I think increasingly I've
recognized that that it may sort of help
set the overall tone of what we worry
about and focus on again remember in
or air pollution you know most people
just never think about that and by by
stressing that I think you can sort of
help people pull people out a little bit
of our sort of normal everyday
experience of what matters and what
doesn't but but fundamentally most
people live in individual nations so you
know I'm increasingly we're still gonna
do the global one every four years or so
so you know every Olympic here but the
rest of the years we actually want to do
this for individual countries so we
started with Bangladesh and now we're
doing Haiti will will will be concluding
that in one and a half months so stand
by and and then we're moving to India so
Tata trust and the Gates Foundation is
funding first two states so mr. Ratan
Tata is very enthusiastic about this he
wants to do the for all twenty-nine
states and the federal level in India
and I think that would be a phenomenal
opportunity imagine actually affecting
the world's biggest democracy and having
you know an opportunity to help make
better decisions for 1.25 billion people
but I also really want to move to first
world you know these are all third row
and and so for a long time had a dream
of doing this first in the US but I
think that's probably wrong right
because this in some ways you just have
such a hyper partisan conversation that
if we tried to do this for instance for
the u.s. you know it would just get
drowned out if anyone dare to say this
is good then the other side would sort
of automatically say that's bad so
possibly for a state we're also thinking
about doing this for education just in
the US a lot of philanthropists are
spending money on education imagine
taking so sort of 40 40 top ideas that
people are talking about for education
and then say if you're gonna spend an
extra dollar it more likely an extra
billion dollars in this what does the
evidence show that that will do a
benefit so you basically get the bang
for buck this list but just for
education just for the US and again it's
just a menu it doesn't there's a lot of
things that doesn't tell you so you
can't just have that conversation and do
the sort thing but
at least it'll start focusing people and
saying you know do the top things in
education so possibly us for a while us
off the board for that what developed
country would comes to mind they would
really like to just so I I live in
Prague now for a variety of reasons the
the Danish government we had a incoming
center-left government and they ran on a
promise to cut off my funding so so when
they did I I moved to Prague and and the
Czech Republic is actually thinking
about doing this so that could be one I
think you know honestly I think all
countries could yeah I would love to see
all countries in the world do this I'm
going to take a really socialist country
and do this in a really non socialist
country you can probably think of a good
one that not us that comparing to
trashed who can make better value of
this kind of analysis of their situation
yeah I I would tend to think anyway
first of all I think if you try to do
that that'd be intellectually
interesting but the two countries would
just care about what we found in their
respective countries and also I think
most countries will just want to take
you know there'll be some things that
will end up taking up and there will be
a lot of things that they'll just leave
on the plate one other thing I found you
know we've worked a lot on getting this
into newspapers because at the end of
the day and if any of you or academics
you know this sense you know there's a
lot of incredibly interesting stuff that
gets written and never read and and in
some way that's just you know terrible
but you know if it's not read if it's
not adopted by a lot of people it kind
of didn't exist so in Bangladesh we we
we wrote up all of this research for
Bangladesh in the biggest
english-speaking which is 250,000 copies
and the biggest Bangla speaking which is
10 million people everything in
Bangladesh is big but but but the
amazing thing is this guy everyone
talking because then you know there's an
article about how do you do education to
Bangladesh if you're from Bangladesh
it's incredibly interesting if you're
not is probably not right but but the
but the point is you want to read this
and then there
what can we do about infrastructure and
how much will that cost how much good
will do it's incredibly interesting so
we ended up writing 24 articles in each
one of those areas and a lot of other
articles in other papers we got everyone
talking about this everyone who's
anything in Bangladesh has one of these
or at least they have gotten one but I
think I've seen quite a quite a number
of who still have them because you'll
you know if you're advocating one of
these long lives you'll constantly be
saying that and then sort of you know it
catches on because then next time you
want to do something of these you're
like you know they're gonna ask you why
do you want to do yeah so so so you know
you start having this conversation that
are slightly more rational and and that
was my sort of end point you also end up
with a situation where journalists will
now start asking this very very simple
question whenever a politician opened
his mouth you'll say I'm sorry sir how
much will that cost and how much good
will it do and that'd be cool right
imagine if we had that conversation more
generally so the you're leading
countries these are countries that have
diasporas you're gonna work in India and
EISs huge-ass prove peoples done very
well all over the world have money they
go back many do does that bear relation
to how you would look at these
developing countries that have no sense
of developed diaspora that's a good
question I haven't thought of it about
I'll definitely bring it bring it along
yeah okay it would be interesting sir to
include that in the way than the
economic analysis what those folks who
went out and did well they they were
based on probably some education and
some other opportunities that you know
made happen they didn't cough themselves
to death and bad fire in the inside the
indoor pollution situation and in in so
that must be part of the multipliers but
it's a loop and figuring out how that
loop play should be for you no no that's
that's a very good point I I would tend
to say and and this is one of the things
that we do that's I think crucial that
this cannot be you know some white guy
that comes in and tells you know
Bangladesh for Haiti how they should do
this so that's why we work with everyone
in Haiti or in Bangladesh we have them
do all the all the the the right things
to focus on and and you know what
in Bangladesh nor in Haiti did diaspora
come up but that's probably you know
because that I could very well be
because there's a blind spot in those
countries you know you you kind of don't
think about all those new poppy is it
left in there yeah they should have
stayed here I don't know but but but but
there's another people in the country
think about the country in the certain
areas you saw in Haiti and in Bangladesh
people who grew up in the country and
it's left which is very strong feeling
for the contract think about the country
in another way probably a little closer
to the way you think about it as a
relation to the ration so we're funded
by Canada in in Haiti so the Canadian
Development Agency the Global Affairs
Canada sort of unofficially say that
they've spent a billion dollars in Haiti
and you know they're not quite sure what
they got for that so that's why they're
really frustrated and they want to do
better in Haiti but we've heard I have
no idea whether that's true but you know
it seems to be the case that Trudeau is
actually really interested in this
project and that's because he has a lot
of Diaspar in his local constituents and
in Montreal well you know free trade in
the world immigrants there's lots of
stuff going on you're up thank you for
doing this
hey thank you very much
[Music]